believe the hype Spider-Man across the
spiderverse is somehow better than the
first movie this film really transcends
every aspect of animation and film like
obviously the biggest draw here is the
crazily inventive and unique art style
that goes Hammond every single frame but
across the spiderverse is also a damn
good movie on its own the script is
filled with so much heart emotion
massive dramatic moments great twist the
dialogue is quick Snappy and so down to
earth and real and with all of this and
how engaging the plot of the movie is it
also finds time to regularly make you
laugh with natural jokes that aren't
forced this movie is simultaneously one
of the best dramas action movies and
even comedies at times the characters
feel effortlessly funny in the Charisma
exuding from everyone is so palpable
basically everyone here is a standout
but miles's parents get a big emphasis
in this movie and the care they have for
Miles spills out and in facts the entire
movie making it deeply in endearing
because of this miles's drive in the
later part of the movie completely wins
you over and gives you chills from how
much great setup there is they spoil the
second act twist in the trailer but I'll
refrain from saying it just in case you
don't know about those plot details then
all of this love is contrasted by a
great villain in Miguel O'Hara who is
played by Oscar Isaac he's so menacing
and easily steals scenes from how big of
a presence he is he's also kind of
inherently designed as the anti-thesis
to this movie and that the movie is
really energetic fun and fast but Miguel
is a depressed figure filled with sorrow
anger and an ounce of Envy the moment he
shows up stands out much more because of
how dark and serious he is he contrasts
the tone and feel of the movie and Timmy
this makes him stand out even more as
the villain his point of view is
completely logical and his motivation is
never in question and is also right
these two opposing sides reminds me of
Captain America's Civil War where each
side is good but they have fundamentally
conflicting views for how they achieve
the right thing it makes the conflict
that much better because it forces miles
to make groundbreaking decisions
throughout the movie he's not just
battling a generic bad guy with flat
motivations but a character that forces
him to reevaluate who he is as a
character and superhero across the
spider versus a surprising 2 hours and
20 minutes long which is pretty unheard
of for an animated movie This Means Lord
and Miller had no constraints while
making the film they wanted and it
really shows here because they were
completely Unleashed or everyone who is
working on it because the movie has
multiple directors so it was probably a
deeply collaborative process every set
piece is exploding with vibrant and
crazy energy and I think the set piece
with all the Spider-Man is probably one
of my favorite sequences in a film it
does not let up for a second and the
attention to detail in every shot is
truly staggering it was overwhelming but
in a good way like no wonder why it took
them so long to make this movie all also
at no point does the movie feel like
it's overly utilizing fan service cameos
because there are definitely cameos
within the movie but they never feel
forced or detract from what's going on
like there's so much casual quick
moments that made the theater go wild
and the directors don't dwell on it for
a whole minute like no way home the
creators know that the story they want
to tell is their priority and don't want
to cheap out within your face fan
service that halts the momentum also
speaking of momentum the pace is
lightning fast for 2 hours and 20
minutes which really isn't a surprise
due to the pace of the first movie but
this could have been three to four hours
and I wouldn't have noticed it's just
pure Bliss and the splurge and run time
is refreshing because they can flesh out
more characters like Gwen Stacy there's
basically an entire prologue to the
movie that tells her story and that in
of itself was amazing it could have
ended there as a short story and I would
have been happy also within this segment
of the film The creators establish a
unique visual language in that each
Universe has its own distinct style
Gwen's world really utilized Punchy and
bright colors that washed over every
inch of the frame and they even get
creative with matching things like the
background bleeding away while Gwen is
getting upset it isn't an understatement
about how revolutionary and creative
this film is for animation it makes the
first film feel like a test run every
landscape shot is an instant screensaver
the transitions are constantly fresh
they play with the frame rate in fun
ways again and how it impacts different
characters the style of a universe
carries over into the physical character
the action is so well captured and the
creators are always experimenting
visually unrelated to Spider-Man there's
the scene in the show Arcane where a
character utilizes time travel in a
fight and while doing so the art style
drastically changes and turns into a
beautiful Showcase of experimental
animation now imagine this level of
creativity but spread out over 2 hours
and 20 minutes the action is constantly
putting you into a bewildered State
because of this across the spider versus
simply one of the best and if not the
best animated movie ever made in my
opinion which is actually a pretty hard
title given Pixar's lineup those movies
May technically have better scripts but
the presentation of across the
spiderverse excels the movie into a
league that is incomprehensible this is
already shaping up to be one of the
highest rated movies on letterbox which
really isn't surprising if I had the
option I'd probably give it six stars
due to how much the animation blew me
away I haven't felt this level of joy
and shock from Pure quality in a long
time or really not that long since John
Wick 4 just came out and that was an
action Masterpiece if this is the level
of creativity That animated movies are
heading towards like with how great the
last Puss in Boots was and hopefully the
new Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles then
this is going to be a golden age for
animation thank you for watching and for
any regular viewers I'll put an update
about the whole demonetization situation
in the community tab but let me know in
the comments if this movie exceeded your
expectations because it somehow did for
me and they were Sky High
foreign